I wonder what kinds of predictions you
made at the beginning of the lesson
would you raise your hand if you
predicted it that a would win hands up
straight okay
I count 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 people
and so hand up now if you predicted big
ones win 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15
okay sure Steve now if you have a look
it seems quite evenly split it's pretty
close
how many eighths have one looks like
seven and how many base six it's very
close isn't it okay now I'm very
interested in two things number one I
want to understand why this happened and
number two remember I asked you to pick
and B at the beginning of the game
before you knew any of the rules about
how this works right but in reality
usually need a little bit about how
something works and you get to choose
right so in future what nothing else is
going to help you actually work out okay
no chances are better here or there we
were quite Mystics of sort of not born
out well so why is that now underneath
where you are working this morning right
we introduced all these different ideas
the most recent that idea we introduced
was remember what is the last a bit of
language that I gave you what sample
space good now right under that I want
you to write down the probability and
this time we're not just thinking to
think about the general and concept
we're going to introduce some my hard
concepts here that I going to actually
help you understand this idea in fact
I'm going to give you the formula right
so if you want to work out the
probability of an event there's lots of
ways to describe it you can just use
words like more likely less likely
guaranteed definitely not but we want to
be a little
in Baracoa this little more precise so
we're going to write a big mole fraction
and I'm gonna explain it as we go okay
all of the numerator of the fraction the
way we're kept probability is and I'll
explain this after we've written it the
number of favorable I'll explain that
outcomes
now just think back to the morning
what's an outcome again like not just
the general word but in probability
what's our definition for outcome it's
very very close that's connected to the
center of samples traceable we get early
I'm graduating or rented a little bit
yeah it's like what happens at the end
you do the experiment what's the result
what will happen what event will take
place at the end that's the outcome okay
now when I say favorable maybe you want
to draw an arrow to that and what we
mean by favorable is the ones that
you're interested right what you're
interested in so for example for player
a what outcome were they interested in
what were they interested in rolling a
six trait a six for player ie their
favorable outcome was a six now that's
the numerator function what's on the
bottom it's also number but it's not the
number of favorable outcomes it's the
number of possible outcomes now we
already have a name for this we just
mentioned that like one do you know what
we call to see it this is the sample
space okay so this part now the bottom
here is the size of the sample space
okay now let's use this idea to unpack
this game and see what's going on okay
the probability and just to abbreviate
this to the victor will just write the
letter P you're gonna get sick of
writing we're probably over
the probability of rolling a six on a
dime okay
what is the chance of rolling a six my
god now think about it through the lens
of this right this is player eight right
here what's the six how many of the
sides on the die are sixes oh it's just
the one right so the number of favorable
outcomes is just one now what's the
sample space it's one two three four
five six so the size of the sample space
is six so this is the probability of
rolling a six right it's one out of six
a six I could write that as a percent of
what is what's east as a yes
it's about I could actually say it
exactly it's sixteen point six for
peanut person okay so just like if
you're Col from fractions decimals and
percentages you can write it as a
fraction you can find in specific you
come back there's a decimal zero put one
six six six six six six it's all the
same okay all right now that was play
array right what was the favorite
outcome that player B was looking for
pushing okay good so I could write this
in a couple different ways I could say
one two three four five right that's the
favorable outcome for player B I could
also just say bought a six
like I just any meat by six right so I
can say not seeks these are the same
thing right now again I'm gonna ask the
question how many are outcomes are not
six on the faces of the diet yeah
what just before it's my fine what about
the size of the sample space it's still
six has changed okay
yeah so 5/6 is the chance on any given
wall the player B is going to actually
make a get get points on them all right
now consider let's have a look at these
games here now there are all the varying
lengths as you can see okay I'm
interested in working out what are the
chances what are the odds
okay so let's just the imagine your
fictitious game of say or let's say
let's go no no one of these games but
let's say your phone I don't know sixty
rollers let's go for 60 that's quite a
few balls ok well let's find out that's
actually all crunching the numbers
together so imagine a game where you
roll exactly 60 times if the puppy that
you're getting a six is one in every six
then how many sixes should you expect to
get how many would you expect thank you
for raising yes to kill Kevin very good
ok so I expect I predict to roll 10
sixes right 10 sixes so how many points
will player a score in this game Frank
okay very good
hey we'll get a hundred and forty points
okay but hold on a second if he's got
ten sixes that means every single other
roll was a lot six do you agree with
that so how many is that I expect all
5050 other numbers
right this is just a lot of expectation
this is just my prediction right so how
many points does that mean for B hello
crunch the number okay thank you
150 now I will just point out Oh what
have you made this really hard for
yourself here's them because you are up
you're tallying as you went so we never
player aims one you did this yet for ten
points one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen yeah and it took a very long
time in your name miscounted it may have
been just quicker or plan a to say I won
once and then twice and then three times
and bad x 14 just like we did here now
have a look this is just like a pretend
game who won who won b1 right it is
pretend game now as you can see play a
isn't always gonna roll exactly ten
sixes what would have happen if they're
brought eleven what would they have
scored instead 140 yeah
hydron 54 right but if they roll one
extra six then these guys are gonna roll
one less of the other numbers right so
how many other numbers were there all
about fifty then 149 which means how
many points are they gonna score yeah
three less than that right 147 so you
can see if just one roll goes the other
way then the table set and that's what
accounts for this do you see this right
this is actually a remarkably close to
fair game that's why it's almost 50/50
you can see one roll one way or the
other
makes the game a different winner does
that make sense which is what you want
out of a good game you don't want the
same person to win every single time
that's a bit bored question
okay now look look what always does kind
of come into it however he's the
interesting right
let's have a look who was the worst the
worst loser out of the beans is that
okay well you could argue that that's a
really sad loss there but we expected a
to lose we expected a to lose right
I think it was stock one might be this
is pretty bad right that's a pretty bad
loss like this one's close this one's
reasonably close who is this
oh yeah it's not it's not my spot in
fact if you roll enough times you should
expect that sometimes able win okay as a
new happen okay